yeah yeah you're sit on a beach and just
watch the waves come in they're all the
same size I'm in a big wave comes in
after that that's yeah that's the big
wave right there hey what's going on
everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones it's
the show with hot questions and even had
our wings and today I'm joined by mkbhd
marques Brownlee he's YouTube's tech
shaman the Shorty Awards creator of the
decade one of the most popular reviewers
on the internet for good reason but how
does he handle his death wings we'll
find out today marques welcome to the
show thanks for having me and I know
that this is a long time coming but
before we get started I do have to ask
how are you a spicy food
I think I'm average I don't really think
I'm Way better than average or really
bad at this I think we'll find out
though we will find out today
you ready get it going he's dead
[Music]
alright alright sorry kind of that's a
kick that's that's hot sauce if not just
sauce and hot sauce alright we're in
there so you've built a YouTube channel
off of schooling the masses and what's
new and popping in the world of text I
think that it's only fair that we give
the people the marques Brownlee gift
guide for 2018 on wing 1 let's say I
have 300 dollars to spend on headphones
first do I even need to spend $300 on
headphones if that's my budget what
should I get 300 bucks is a nice little
it's a nice low price range for
something like headphones because you're
definitely serious about it but with 300
bucks you start to get into like
discerning difference between like it's
sennheiser over-ear versus an open back
you get different styles Wireless wired
a personal favorite of mine is audio
Technica's and 50s and they are way
under 300 men those was like 160 170
there's a lot of different things you
can do at that price so it's a good
place to shop have you ever used the
phrase thank God I was wearing my Google
glasses no never never once I actually
that was a weird time so I like actually
tried to use them walking around the
street and just never once was it
something I was super happy to have on
if you could steal one item out of Casey
nice dad's studio what would you grab oh
wow mm-hmm
that's a good question he's got a lot of
stuff in there he's got drones he's got
cameras he's got lenses but I would
probably take something like the one
wheel or some ridiculous electric
transportation that I don't have yet but
I want to try but I'd take some lessons
with it because there's no way I'd be
good on it and then one of the great
barroom takes of our era is that porn is
the real driver of innovation when it
comes to technology
yeah is that true in your opinion have
you ever given the matter any thought I
think it's true I know for a fact Google
is a number one most viewed website I
know YouTube is the second most popular
website Facebook I think just a reddit
just past Facebook is number three but
I'm sure as far as like volume there's a
couple porn sites that do major
traffic and have major influence over
what people do with their online time so
they are big drivers naughty America or
bangbros oh man I have no thang bro
Justin sounds better
JK everyone knows it's brazzers you
ready to move on marques let's do it
that one I could do every day I like
that I like to label too that's clean
black and white damn I'm giving them a
bottle I know you hate it I'm giving it
a bottle put it in the back so tech news
usually stays at the Maven cob but
nothing seems to really bubble up and
the pop-culture space quite like Apple
product announcements what confuses you
what annoys you when non tech people
cover Apple
I mean Apple is probably the most
popular company out there so there's a
lot of people who just kind of
peripherally are aware of how massive
they are and with that you always get
people who ignore the tech and just
focus on the fact that people are big
Apple fans I call you an Apple fanboy
they'll say you're a mindless sheep if
you like Apple at all no matter what
your reasoning someone's gonna say that
I think some people are mindlessly just
getting the next iPhone just because
it's the next iPhone but as someone who
actually likes to put thought into and
analysis of products it's kind of weird
to get that from people what's the worst
Apple take that you've ever heard from a
civilian on the street they just react
strongly to change so when Apple does
anything whether it's removing a
headphone jack or having a notch at the
top of the screen they just hate it
there's plenty of things they've done
that I thought were great that people
just hated cuz it was different but it's
mostly just a just a reaction to it
being different so I was watching a
video of you on Instagram playing
ultimate frisbee and I don't know what
my expectations were exactly but it
wildly exceeded my expectations that's
that's a great compliment I'm doing my
job then
[Applause]
Wow I went to Columbia high school and
maple in New Jersey where the sport was
invented in 1968 so that's where the
first games were played I think a friend
or two and just said hey come out to a
practice you might like it and I haven't
stopped playing since what's the most
disrespectful move that you can pull in
the ultimate pitch like is there any
posterization equipment there is it's
the Vince Carter it's jumping over
somebody it doesn't happen that much I
can say I have done it unfortunately it
wasn't on video there is a photo version
of it do it
alright we're in there son of zombie so
it's like not the zombie apocalypse I
remember that from previous seasons
alright the Sun is on be
this is definitely a sleeper mm-hmm I'm
nervous cuz a lot of these feel tame and
I take big bites and then I don't know
what's about to hit me how is it that
all these youtubers seem to be able to
impulse buy Tesla's and I'm in the back
of a lift just scraping the cushions for
spare change man Tesla is a fun company
that's been a dream car of mine for so
long I've been saving up for it for so
many years since the the curse that is a
test-drive
there wasn't any stopping me once I was
able to boom but I think it's just a
it's just a great all-around car I don't
know something about it is just really
appealing and it's attracted and I love
it and then the cult of the Tesla has
really grown in recent years can you
give me the layman's explanation for why
the Tesla is such a big deal well the
car itself is great it starts with that
if it wasn't a great car it wouldn't
hold up Brian knows this hype around
like all these features and you get in
it looks like a spaceship it's the
fastest car on the street just kind of
hyped up its reputation a little burning
out once you get in it and you get
floored zero to 60 or you hear it's
silent it lives up to it so I think just
the fact that it's actually a great
product is the core part of that what's
your response to Trick Daddy who says
that you can't trust a self-driving car
because as he puts it all computers
malfunction yeah you know what he's got
a point it's been a whole thing lately
about just people getting really worked
up understandably about self-driving
cars crashing it'll happen but the fact
that the computer is less likely to
crash than a human is a great place to
start so I would say to him give it a
chance you might be impressed with its
obstacle avoidance or it's super fast
reaction times in a way that you might
not find in human
so this next one is the lowest calientes
this is one of the hot ones sauces
Marquez we sent you some hot sauce yeah
because you know we appreciate the love
and you were kind enough sorry I'm gonna
choke this down first you are generous
enough to rate the hot ones fiery
Chipotle eight out of ten this is our
new one the lows calientes do you think
it stacks up I'm in a spot right now
where I like this more than the old one
spice is cool but it's the flavor we're
calling it the sauce of the summer
all right marques as you know we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that Graham where you do a deep
dive on our guest Instagram and put
interesting pictures that need more
context so I'll bust out the laptop I'll
show you the picture then you just tell
me the bigger stories that sound good
sounds great all right Steven laptop
please laptop and pedestal and pedestal
all right first things first
UNM dt yeah he's been in the hot seat I
love that video that was an amazing
episode this particular one he's
pointing at the PI on my shirt because
he was slightly bothered that my shirt
had a bunch of different multiplication
and division and signs and things like
that but PI didn't really belong but I
justified it to them I was like you know
it's a beautiful mathematical symbol so
leave it alone but I know more digits of
pi than him that's on my resume little
foreshadowing we'll be putting that to
the test a little bit later oh wow
speaking of things worth the price the
air mags not those those are now at the
price those are ridiculous if I'm
reviewing like Footwear I'm never
recommending notice ever what do you
remember about them
they're heavy very heavy they've got
these big batteries and big lights
that's the thing about these shoes is
people don't know like they look cool
they've got lights in them and they're
self-lacing but you need batteries and
motors and lights and all those things
are heavy
they're clunking around in these shoes
and they look dope and you could picture
with them and they're awesome but
they're not they're not daily driver
material
[Music]
somes got like a red hue to it
[Music]
mm-hmm you can just put it up oh yeah
yeah never sit on a beach and just watch
the waves come in they're all the same
size I mean a big wave comes in after
that that's yeah that's the big wave
right there it's coming it's coming
cool when's the last time you got super
angry or annoyed by a gadget the last
time you just wanted to Gronk's bike
whatever you're holding mmm
there's probably yesterday or something
technically speaking you write the code
and it should work and when it doesn't
work it's confusing and frustrating
whenever software doesn't work it just
bugs me well if that bugs you here's
that one I do I want to give you some of
the things that bug me and I want you to
tell me if I'm justified in my rage or
if I'm just being a big baby about the
whole thing okay
Apple losing the headphone jack is that
just something that was destined to
happen or is this just another example
of them playing God with their customers
a little bit of both I feel like you're
okay to be mad about that I think
everyone is Apple is justification is we
want to move to this Wireless future and
in order to get rid of all these ports
on the iPhone and make it truly Wireless
we got to get rid of the headphone jack
eventually we're gonna have to get rid
of the data port the charging they took
the step one and people got pretty
pissed and I'm not surprised at all how
come we can put a rover on Mars but I
can't get decent Wi-Fi on a Delta flight
I think about that every day right
that's the most fret speaking of being
frustrated slow Wi-Fi is so much worse
than no Wi-Fi and then they had the
balls to charge like $36 or like 45
bucks or whatever on one flight you know
silly the amount of money they make off
people who don't actually get anything
for it is crazy
what's your elevator pitch for why we
should be allowed to edit our tweets
oh that's a great question we should be
able to edit our tweets because we're
human we make mistakes so just for like
30 seconds after I tweet just let me you
get that reply that says hey you spelled
that wrong I may just add the apostrophe
let me just add that extra letter I
forgot I'm not gonna change it to make
it a completely different thing if I do
you'll see the Edit history and you'll
know so yeah we should go edit tweets
I'm sweatin let's say sixteen out of ten
heat label Deeds work those hot ones
fans know we have an unhealthy obsession
and what our guest eats I have to ask
you about the industrial size boxes of
honey nut cheerios that I see lurking in
your videos yeah can you explain your
love for Cheerios for me I was doing
videos in college and there's this thing
about cameras where you set your shutter
speed and sometimes there's a little
flicker maybe a microwave behind you and
your college dorm has a display that
kind of blinks in a weird way so that
was happening it was behind me and after
a couple of videos in a row in front of
that microwave there's some comments
about it
hmm huh so high I took something from my
box of Cheerios just played it in front
of microwave to show know people who
won't comment about that anymore
get back to the content of the video you
know but people who found the videos
after that point and didn't know why I
put them there didn't know why they were
behind me didn't know about the
microwave and they assumed a love for
Cheerios which I have not denied to this
day yet but that's how it happened
well I know that Cheerios its goat
status for you but what I want to do is
show you some other Titans of the
breakfast aisle and I just want you to
rank these cereals yeah from best to
most trash corn pops Apple Jacks Cocoa
Krispies frosted flakes and Froot Loops
I have a feeling this is gonna make some
people mad
it always does unjustifiably but this is
a clear number one Apple Jacks one Apple
Jacks at number one I'm gonna go frosted
flakes number two I'm gonna go Froot
Loops three and I'm gonna go Cocoa
Krispies followed by pops as a tech dude
have you ever thought about just
drinking Soylent for efficiency I tried
it really yeah it's not technically I
have thought about it it was trashed it
tastes so bad it tastes like it sounds
Soylent yeah just not good
alright marques now we've arrived we've
arrived
[Music]
no place to hide
[Music]
yeah
yeah all right hmm so through doing this
show I've been exposed to this whole
world of insufferable hot sauce snob so
I can only imagine what you must go
through dealing with these tech geeks
all the time hmm when you look at the
comments on the video so the things that
get tweeted at you what are the things
that make you wish that maybe your
reviewed breakfast cereals rather than
smartphones I like that I review
something that people use all the time
tech is a part of your life you know so
uh on one hand people may get purchased
and they want to justify it and they
will at all costs no matter what I
bought this iPhone I spent a thousand
bucks on it you can't tell me this isn't
the best phone and then I come along and
tell them about another phone was better
and they I want to hear it so I get that
it's frustrating but I get it haha Wow
but yeah that's a thing what about
locking horns with celebrities what's
the story behind how a gal gadot blocked
you on Twitter
I'd like to think it was personally her
but that's a fun story she is spot
sponsored by Huawei basically her whole
Twitter feed one day an uber I noticed
she's tweeting for an iPhone I thought
it was funny
took a screenshot of it tweeted it and
soon I was getting some emails and calls
from people she works with how'd you
find this how did you know what gets
public like you can just look and see
but I well I think at that point I
followed her because I wasn't following
her someone just like told me I look at
it so I followed her a couple days later
someone sends me a tweet like hey she
tweeted from an Android phone like oh
really and I go to check and I'm blocked
and I can't see any of it so clearly
they don't want me snooping anymore that
is not a good label as long as I'm here
I'm gonna review something and it's the
labels on these bottles and they just
got really bad but this last one you
know I don't want to put you on the spot
or whatever but could you rank them up
for us like can you change the order or
something of the labels based on labels
yeah this is the best label just the
best bottle heartbeat heartbeat number
one black label number two it's not a
clean label this looks like something
you'd find on a less painful thing so
that's number three then I'm gonna go
this hot ones summer days
it's high I gotta admit it is summery
that's what we're going for and now I'm
gonna pull right up with a pirate's
Lantern the last ABS got a nice label
there you go then we'll go howler monkey
and go on the bomb with as much pain as
it caused me today
I'm gonna go zombie apocalypse cuz it's
got a novelty factor at least yeah yeah
but this reflective garbage font has got
to go mad please
well let's hope that the wings better
than the label
[Music]
can't really get worse I guess all right
you went to the Stevens Institute of
Technology and at the time you'd had the
YouTube notoriety that you have now what
was the best and worst thing about being
internet famous as a college student the
worst thing was a professor that asked
me to be a guest for my own class it was
a social media class by the way so it
made sense I was really just no please I
don't want to do that but I did it but
the best part of it was actually like
right after college when everyone's you
know doing a job search thing I was
lucky enough to be in a position where I
kind of knew that this is what I could
do full-time and so I just dedicated
full cement to that there it is there it
is all right Marcus
this is the last dab products as you
know it's tradition around here to put a
little extra on the last wing I don't
have to if you don't want to I don't
want to but here we are
there is textbook
[Music]
filling it let's good stuff alright
marques here we are at the scoville
finish line and what we're gonna be
doing is a throw the kitchen sink Adam
Decathlon style wing ten challenge all
right well your heads about to explode
like a damn volcano quick how many
digits in PI can you reset up the top of
your head right now alright three point
is the first one count 3.14159265 three
five it might be wrong we'll
double-check it in post but our next
question comes from YouTube
it comes from youtuber Casey and Casey
and got it who wanted us to focus on
your squeaky voice in early videos his
question what was it like to go through
puberty on camera man you right Casey uh
my I had the best the best comment I
ever heard about that was that I sound
like Elmo and my first video and I
really do sound like Elmo in my first
video so don't go watch that and then
last but not least certainly not least
would you mind busting out your camera
and taking a picture of this still life
known as the hot ones aftermath and then
talking through your creative process in
as much detail as possible look I'm
gonna I'm a fan of shallow
depth-of-field
it's something you usually get with
DSLRs but if we feature this hot ones
sauce right in the middle you've got a
pretty sweet lighting setup going
already I don't have to do much work if
you want to minimize the depth of field
you want to get the subject as close to
the camera as possible and the
background is far away so make these
back we're gonna end up yeah if you want
to back these up with that the cap is
off of the last dab so you end up with a
sort of a live action oh boy
Oh nope we don't need that it's not as
pretty but I'll end up with a little you
wanna give a thumbs up in the background
we do it's pretty solid
it is beautiful with the power of post
let's put it on the screen and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you my friend this
camera this camera or this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life look I just want to talk
tech with people who are interested so
if you're trying to buy something you
need a recommendation I'll try to do my
best with that our review tech on my
youtube channel youtube.com slash mkbhd
or those five letters anywhere instagram
twitter thanks for watching aloha spice
lords if you're wondering why I'm
sitting on this beautiful beach it's
because I'm celebrating Lowe's calientes
the sauce of summer in the newest
addition to the hot ones hot sauce
family this is Beach vibes in a bottle
sweet smoky spicy and I might be biased
but I think it's the best hot sauce
we've ever made and here's the exciting
news if you want to pick up a bottle
it's available now you know the drill
heat nice calm heat nice calm for your
bottle of lows calientes louis calientes
muy delicioso
[Music]